so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys uh welcome to the dope
as usual podcast I am Thomas dobizola
whatever you want to call me I'm here
with my co-host Martian what's up folks
what's up we're back again guys we're
back again with a highly requested guest
and no he's not related to me I know we
look a lot alike this is Juno duno's
world how you doing man yes sir my guys
I know y'all man I'm doing great I'm
doing great just a little a little rough
patches on the way you know starting off
the week a little rub but I'm okay we're
right here podcasting so yeah blessed
you know what I mean and just to say it
every for all the big dudes out there
stretch stretch you just told me what
happened to your back go oh
deteriorating discane
me too he's like the back of your knee
you just gave him a whole consultation
because I know I've been going through
for so long bro yeah man like I ain't
gonna lie I was
so like the back Pain's been there so
it's like lower back it's for me it's my
left side I don't know if you use your
left or right which is okay you're
switching okay my right side is stupid
crazy good like my right side it's ready
for a football game
unless I could do some golfing oh no
maybe maybe some cuddling is pretty much
it right cuddling because golfing after
that swing I just went oh my back you
know what I mean so
it feels like so let's say this is my
back right and it just feels like
there's something holding it and if I go
like this it like moves so it's like
kind of stuck so I feel like I just I'm
I have like a like my crap is very
consistent in my lower back did probably
yeah and then it goes and then I'm
thinking you know I'm I'm a [ __ ]
overthinker dog so I'm over here like
[ __ ] it's cancer it's [ __ ] diabetes
Imma die my mom don't got this [ __ ] but
my grandma got this [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] my grandma diabetes Queen I
mean not like that but like she's like
losing her eyesight a little so it's a
little scary you know he's like that too
you know so so I'm over here thinking
like [ __ ] my [ __ ] my cousin the only one
that's my age she just got this [ __ ] and
hell she tell us like she's healthy
she's skinny but you know your family
but she's in my family so that [ __ ] skip
generation my mom didn't get it but I'm
like damn and I'm the biggest my sister
is healthy you know what I mean so I'm
like damn one of my stuff I'm like what
am I fat I just got diabetes but I went
to the doctor um I went to the ER
actually I was there for almost like 10
plus hours dog
last night last night I saw I got home
like at three went to sleep like at four
woke up and came here appreciate it yeah
yeah we've had fools go you know what
I'm I'm feeling a little under the
weather and they just don't show up like
so thank you I appreciate that [ __ ] I'm
in the hospital still showed up yeah I
know so [ __ ] we feeling good man we're
feeling a little better taking some
ibuprofen technology yeah but the bright
side of that story is you just dropped a
big ass weight plate yeah yeah yeah so
so in my head I'm like diabetes but I'm
like damn diabetes why couldn't you get
me before I started working out because
then I would have been super extra
motivated I was when are you what's your
birthday
um two thousand no like what's your
birthday oh March 9th I'll say man you
sound like me like I'll be overthink my
team I knew it was when I was nine and I
didn't take that medicine and look what
happened like I always overthink like
that you what is it my head hurts it's a
[ __ ] tumor yeah no yeah but my cousin
just got a brain to him like oh my God
is it hereditary yeah stupid
exaggerating dog yeah me too man I
understand
um go ahead so what'd you do to would
you implement to take off that 45 pounds
to get the so um so I was like my
biggest bro I was at 350 dog which is
big bro I'm only
two I just turned 22 so it was like
around May if I'm not mistaken and dogs
like you know like we're on camera so
you see like dog
dude that [ __ ] is stupid crazy food so I
don't notice you don't notice like me my
sweater fits yeah I ain't [ __ ]
gaining weight and then you see a
picture from two months ago like shut
the [ __ ] up yeah and that was the good
time my thing my um my breaking point
was the
breathing hard
like mayor like like like A.D or Tira
will be talking or Lefty
and I'm like oh my God I'm fat as [ __ ]
dog and I'm like
it's that but if you touch her I'm like
and then you're sitting yeah you watch
your back like oh you're a fat piece of
[ __ ] yeah you die you might as well go
out like on 600 whatever life whatever
the [ __ ] that is like that's how bad it
was bro and I was on my biggest 350 um
and me and AD did a food show bro
and um we we have this fusional jumper
Now call we hungry where we go around
try different foods and stuff like that
right and we did um the first episode we
did Yamashiro what's that
um it's a restaurant in the Hollywood
Hills it's like dope shout out she
connected us and I'm sitting there dog
and I'm wearing all white which is not a
good idea you're like a painter yeah you
know what I mean not even a painter dog
but it just made me look stupid extra
fat like like you know what I mean like
bro I got a black shirt on you know what
I mean like that like that's just made
me look crazy you know just think about
your 15 year old stuff like did you
think you'd be here you fat [ __ ] that's
how I feel sometimes like you're fat
yeah damn it were you always really
heavy or was it I mean yeah I mean I
mean I was always big but like it was
never like an issue for me especially
like me kind of like being in the
streets a lot like guy me fences tagging
and stuff like that like being like I
could climb fast like a [ __ ]
maybe not not with the with the with the
whatever the [ __ ] I got in the back of
my [ __ ] but you know what I mean now I
might take me a little while but like I
was like my biggest foot out and I
looked back at that video like
hell no I look crazy boo I feel you I
look I look I look I look I'm fat you
look unhealthy yeah
I'm like talking about obese food like
these jokes are starting to make sense
you know what I mean the first thing
Adam goes like hey you fat like do you
know the first thing he's asked me on no
jump right though yeah
yeah I know
you think it's a surprise I live in here
[ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] that white
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] that's how I
had him but he but he also he he on a
weight loss Journey too but that's all
that so me and my homies [ __ ] um we
decided to start a bet we're like we all
gonna put 100 bucks and we're not loses
I'm the most weight
is um you know from with the way from
whatever exact month we we did or
however long we said we're gonna do it
which I never got paid by the way you
win I won 100 never got paid because now
I'm addicted to the gym oh okay like
this is what I do in like two a days you
know I take pre-workout I don't smoke we
do I don't smoke weeds so you can't do
two days and you'll be smoking weed yeah
when I stopped smoking I did two days
since May which is like May 45 since May
yeah so would you say because I'm gonna
do a book on this right now was it about
like two months when you felt like this
is a habit now yeah yeah yeah so so I'm
I'm very much
um I'm very much dedicated I'm very much
excited to do it every day when I don't
do it I feel weird I feel like unhealthy
I feel like a fat [ __ ] like you know
like when I eat hot cheetos like I feel
disgusting of myself yeah when I'm drunk
and I happen to like I've been very
disciplined on like not eating past 10
p.m or damn hot Cheetos or or drinking
soda I've been I've been very different
gotta [ __ ] your workout over here I've
tried to drink a soda because that's the
only option and me just being used to
like a gas and like the the carbon and
all that [ __ ] like it I'm like but it's
too sweet for me now cavities are going
you know I've been to the dentist like
oh yeah you got like one cavity now I've
been before it was like ten I'm like
damn were you silver teeth kid like no I
was nervous to put that back my gums
were stupid ugly like [ __ ] I'm like uh
my [ __ ] look I'm like no one did my
Brave steak no damn no I didn't stick
that bad but I'm like no matter how much
I brush my teeth it was like oh it's
just a little danky you know what I mean
and then and you see things like that
like [ __ ] starting to fit a little
better more you know I mean I don't
breathe
so are you doing cardio are you lifting
weights everything so I have like Monday
I do um Monday's leg day we do always
start off with like 10-15 minutes of the
treadmill 15 incline about 2.5 and just
walk um the gym I go to actually has
like a movie theater room so it's dark
in there so I'm able to like and I only
pay 10 bucks a month by the way what did
you say yeah I'm about to turn the
lights off in the warehouse and you just
use the word that sounds so much more
yeah yeah it's it's it but and it's also
like kind of humid in there so it gets a
good sweat going on and then they
usually play real good movies they have
like days where they play like a bunch
of Adam Sandler movies they have days
where they play like I've been there on
a blessed day where i'm a big Harry
Potter fan so I've never seen them all
never seen them all oh yeah you're
missing I don't know I've seen them all
the last one where [ __ ] just
died I saw that one I was like damn the
kids are dead
like the twin dies with Jesus Christ
yeah [ __ ] Harry lives like of course
you know what I mean Harry's the
red-headed kid uh no no that that's
that's Ronald Weasley that's Ron Weasley
yeah yeah I really don't so you know
what I mean so I it's so I've been like
I've been like real on it you feel me
and then when you're watching a good
movie and you're like you know what I
mean and like when you got [ __ ] like
me you know what I mean on the treadmill
just texting them like yeah yeah you
know what I mean you get motivated by
[ __ ] like that yeah and the [ __ ] have
increased I've always got [ __ ] but
like the level of [ __ ] is just kind of
little [ __ ] I [ __ ] love the way you
said that you know what I mean like like
there was always like nice pretty bad
[ __ ] but now they like stupid bad [ __ ]
you know what I mean and I look better
in clothes you know so it's really good
yeah yeah so it's a real good feeling
but you do got to be dedicated and with
what we do for our careers is hard
I saw right now you were like you want
to drink I was like you know what I mean
like I'm okay oh I meant water
you and I get like sparkly water he's
like I got a bottle I'm like um
I just took some ibuprofen this shit's
over there I kept it over there out of
sight oh yeah please I had a heart
attack right now dude
um so wait you don't smoke weed at all
don't smoke weed stop smoking when I was
16. congratulations but you had been our
week oh yeah yeah man I'm speaking of
sorry I'm up it's been past 10 minutes
I'm gonna let it joint
oh yeah oh it's 12 minutes yeah wait are
you good with sweets
yeah no yes I stopped smoking when I was
like
16 like right fresh out of juvenile like
fresh out of juvenile I did like my my
little six seven month camp program and
I got out and I was like I I smoked once
it was cool I smoked twice I took a bong
rib so I seen the comment where
everybody was like make him take a
banger I'm like bro that [ __ ] would have
changed my life like completely right
now like I probably would go into like a
cave and just cry and like overthink
about life though and that's kind of
what happened to me and like I I mean I
didn't get depressed but I was
definitely like uh the same thing
happened to my wife she went on the pens
program like probation basically had to
stop smoking weed she was 15 and went
back to it freaked her out forever and
they stopped smoking forever oh yeah man
that [ __ ] could get it could [ __ ] you up
bad but I'm so sad because I was hyped
right because I'm like okay I
I usually time there pretty well where I
would I would be like okay I'm gonna get
tested by my probation officer on
Tuesday Tuesday afternoon we're going
stupid Everybody by eights do no smoking
you know at the moment we're going
stupid on Snapchat Snapchat's going up I
got videos I'm gonna send them to y'all
so y'all maybe couldn't say them on this
[ __ ] but like
dog I started tripping so I was like oh
I didn't like after that I was good I
was like yeah I'm cool I'd be so upset
if weed freaked me the [ __ ] out I'd be
like I forced myself into it I feel like
I'd just be freaking the [ __ ] out I know
what you mean it's okay
I don't know what it is I I could I
could be going through an audit I don't
give a [ __ ] or something and I'm like
damn this joint's [ __ ] great I don't
know what it is it just makes me it's
like watching your favorite movie
that's just my face my friend I don't
know I couldn't do it man I don't know
if I could do it how many joints you
smoke a day I don't know
I don't know okay what about like like
grams
um if I'm busy not not a lot but like if
I'm just chilling it's all homies
probably could be 20 grams an ounce 20
but not least not like that no man but
it's not by yourself either right
um maybe no it's by myself if I'm
smoking by myself I'm smoking like a 10
grams nothing like five I usually roll
joints like that though so I'm only like
three of these oh Cassie what you're
saying yeah but this is a little joint
normally real quick before I uh forget
and go into another topic because then
we're talking about some [ __ ]
congratulations on that Pro Club [ __ ] oh
my God I'm rocking it right now let me
see it bro
I just this was a little this was a
little raggedy because I got it first
but hold on you're wearing white you're
you're going to the right the right side
the right
Direction man yeah yeah I wouldn't wear
that [ __ ] yeah but this is you're brave
yeah but this is white with designs
it camouflage it distracts you chameleon
Vibes you know what I mean but hold on
hold on just so people know that's an
official
sponsor oh yeah
I mean I I wouldn't say 100 sponsor but
if that's a partnership man you know
they but yeah it's a collaboration it's
something that we have had in the talks
since I've met them
um the front of the [ __ ] website
right now yeah man I'm in front of the
website I look see but see okay if we
pay attention to that picture I look big
as [ __ ] dog the picture you have all we
had up here the picture you had up there
I look a little you know I mean I mean I
look a little nicer you know I mean so
they just sold you like in in that video
that they released bro you can see my
like tits and love handles going stupid
crazy they was like all kicking it
together like my food my body just looks
like a bunch of [ __ ] cinnamon rolls
dog and when I seen that video they're
like yeah don't know we're gonna collide
with you this one on Monday I'm like
yeah we are thanks and then then the
first thing I did when when it jumped I
had to come in and be like damn I'm fat
no all right come and tell it man you
can see the difference in my weight lies
huh yeah yeah everybody's like yeah we
can yeah we can that's cool to make sure
that they know that wasn't cured yeah
but I'm not capping online
that one is it was filmed about I'm
gonna say a month and a half ago so that
one is good that one is still a weight
loss journey I still look a little
better it's not what I where I am now
but the video Pro clear release where
I'm I'm I have like the the French hat
on and I'm like
that that video I was at my biggest bro
in that video if they had like stupid
audio
man I was tired from riding on a board
dog that [ __ ] is crazy
on the same topic I'm into all that [ __ ]
I'm into all the crank markers and all
this oh yeah yeah our whole set is all
done up and shut yeah yeah I said it's
amazing by the way thank you thank you
well I love how you did that because
it's like it's based around like
typography but it's all little phrases
that mean something to you oh yeah you
did every one of them I did I did every
single phrase on that shirt and those
are phrases that I mean I guess some of
them you you would consider um comical
or
or deep or very influential or very
misunderstood and and there's a lot of
things that I like you know because to
put all in reality I would uh I mean in
the perfect world I wouldn't want
everything to be on there that would
have been in the perfect world but for
the shirt to come out nice sometimes
things got a little cut off with the Pro
Club box logo is right in the middle
so it did come out though but like one
of the ones that came out um one of the
ones that like didn't make it was like
the [ __ ] love one which is just like a
saying that like everybody says but it
was you know it's like
it's just something I think I think
maybe the girls would have felt a little
more but just the way the shirt was put
together it didn't fit I like only the
love part kind of came out which I love
sort of um Shout Out My Guy Brian from
Pro Club I'm not gonna give it to
actually buy you guys might swarm him
with like let me get some Pro Club but
shout out my guy he um he well put it
together where even like something small
like that means it's very significant
like when you're in this graffiti game
or just an art in general sometimes
just the bottom of this of the Sea and
the top of the L might come out and and
the all might be a little lopsided so
you know even though like if you're if
if you're like a graffiti or you're
paying attention very closely to the
shirt you could see that it's like uh
it's safe [ __ ] love if you're like oh
you know you know it's like Common Sense
kind of but like if you are like oh it
is [ __ ] love or like I think the smile
now came out like somehow now but then
the cry kind of got cut off and then
it's like cry later got you you know I
mean so but people were like hey this
this is for small not cry later right
I'm like yeah they're like oh fire imma
get it bro that's my you know that's
like an OD or that's like a very big
saying
um and yeah a lot of things to put out
there um
um I made sure to um um talk about my
homies a lot on there I think I think I
put some [ __ ] like um I'm very big on
calls and I'm just a deep depressed
[ __ ] so I liked that [ __ ] you
know I like to be sad sometimes you know
what I mean so I think I put a lot in
there like
um man I [ __ ] R.I.P my homies that
didn't make it
um I wish you could see this and then I
did some [ __ ] like I put my homie like
long leg up there Muhammad RFP he he
passed away of an overdosed
um I put the homie Julio up there he
also passed away um of an overdose or
like drug related things I put [ __ ] LAPD
I put a sword in my dad smokes crack so
what in my family don't have papers city
of the Skies city of the scandalous I
think I put all the main freeways of of
I guess you would say like California I
guess but like in Los Angeles area I put
the the 101 the 110 the 405 the five the
ten the 710 the 60 I might have missed
like one or two main ones but I put
those up there um
I'm trying to think what else I put it
on my phone oh I put I love you Mom none
of some
um Downtown lake that's where I'm from I
put Latinos
and then yeah there's a couple things in
there man that I put up hipsters I
missed myself yeah oh yeah yeah
kids mom
people from like
um like Highland Park and like Echo Park
which is kind of like the oh I'm from
like the downtown Echo Park area but
people were like bro this [ __ ] is crazy
and
um the video yeah the shirt man a lot
but the video just meant like the shirt
by the way it's like it's all right now
go get it where do you get it at though
um shop at Pro proclibusa.com but you
have to just press the link in my bio
you know I'm because the specific
website but I think it's
shareproclubusa.com you know where they
can get it in person
um no we might do a pop-up not 100 sure
by the time this comes out we might have
something figured out within a week but
if not just go get it online and [ __ ]
like that you should be good quick
shipping by the way we ship all them
into the order comes in proclubusa.com
yeah Pro clubusa.com or go to my bio
you'll see yourself yeah yeah kick it
how did you like did they just recognize
you as like this is just a sick so I
when I started doing skits back in like
2019
um late 2018 middle of 2018 early 2019
and when I kind of started getting my
little more recognition a little more
stardom just through like social media
um cover hit which was like early 2020
yeah which cover hit a week after my
birthday they they pronounced the
lockdown
on March 10th or 11th if I'm not
mistaken or within that week March 12th
March 12th okay we got March 11th uh out
of downtown literally just just I just
missed it okay so my birthday is March
9th
so they literally were like
you know what I mean you're drinking
legally inside yeah and and [ __ ] um
so yeah that happened but um
so I was [ __ ] sorry was the question
again Pro Club Pro Club oh okay yeah
he's smoking it right now yeah now so oh
so I did a skit where I was like yeah
because I do I would do skits and being
from like LA or just anywhere like I
mean just I mean in L.A in particular
because I know we're the one that rocket
the [ __ ] most but just being from Los
Angeles we
I were we were the same black tea it's
not the same one but we wear black tees
All Pro multiple times you know what I
mean like I have like 10 fresh black
teeth at the house I have like 20 fresh
black teeth at the house right now I
feel you you know what I mean that's
like Hood not Flanders out yeah yeah you
know what I mean it's like it's like
it's like Rockies
we had a New York with the white tees it
was the same shirt what is it he said
the hood Ned Flanders from the [ __ ]
Simpsons he wears the same I mean they
all wear the same outfit it's like boom
boy you go in the closet you've got the
same amount for that Homer wasn't it
wasn't Netflix is that the ones with the
with the glasses yeah the neighbor oh
he's a rape what no I'm just I'm just
assuming creep yeah it gives me very
like well he's like an Aryan Nation Dude
too right like oh Netflix
we watched this he has no tattoos with
his kids he's a man of God
yes oh yeah oh okay he's got a priest
he's a church going he's a creepy he's
left-handed racist
like Adolf like I had to go to prison of
Islam all the time only out of jail
different
it's weird it's a long story man okay
it's a long story my Mom married this
fool and he was uh white supremacist and
I used to visit him all the time
you're Mexican yeah and Jewish
he touched you
yeah
I don't know Netflix Netflix
no I'm not I don't think netline is
creepy if you go back and watch now with
those that mind you might be a little
it's just funny it's just it's just I
think like like um did you guys watch
like the okay okay did you guys watch um
so he did that so we did like no jumper
with um with Andrew Schultz yeah okay of
course did he see it and we went on like
a 10 minute round about we made fun of
Adam being touched by his dad because he
has tattoos and it was like the funny it
was comical but isn't it yeah sort of
guy it like towards the end but me
Andrew and AD just mostly Andrew you
know he's a [ __ ] genius bro he's like
the best quick you know what I mean Wick
and he was just [ __ ] like he was just
going to Adam he's like yeah man if you
if you're a white boy with tattoos in
your face you've been touched before
[ __ ] or you got a rap career ahead of
you yeah yeah either that one but I
don't care rap like MGK you know what I
mean but it but Netflix is kind of
creepy I think he's kind of creepy yeah
we started this yeah that Fighters just
agree to disagree no
no I I guess I could get that but
anyways back to topic I was just
watching Jason I was on the Honeydew
this morning
yes tell these stories face completely
tied up crazy I can't believe you're
like a Mexican kid with a racist stepdad
but he didn't know Spanish growing up
until he taught me
your supremacist white stepdad with
lightning bolts and swastikas in his
body and uh Mexican lady
like out of out of prison he looks like
Ned Flanders he's covered up he has no
tats on his face he only keeps the tats
from here down completely covered whole
head but he has hair does he like black
people he's cool my best friend was
black and he was like he never like just
walked by and slapped him behind the
head no he explained it to me like yo
that's in that's in jail I have to be
that person out here I'm your dad and I
go
all right then you start smoking Chris
and then my mom divorced him and it was
over
there you have a contact with him not no
no what if you asked her like hey can I
come on the pod
it's not available
he was so cool as a kid
no because my dad like you said who
cares my dad smoke crack my dad smoked
crack my whole life so my dad was like
I'll see you when I see you I'm like
damn I guess I'll take the racist all
right thanks Mom
he's the coolest guy he's super nice and
fun he's just a jackass yeah it was just
a drug addict yeah you know you know so
hold on let's get on the actual topic I
had uh I asked this question to people
sometimes okay all right and I like to
gauge where you're at
write down if your 16 year old self
walks through that door and try to fight
you are you gonna beat this [ __ ] out of
him or he's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
you
oh [ __ ]
you know you think yourself at 16 like
I'll beat the [ __ ] out of myself this is
my six year old me
um because my six year old me was in
shape so hold on how old you say you
were I'm 22. six years a long time
though okay
you're a full grown damn I started doing
the math
uh 16. I'll beat the dog [ __ ] out there
he's working out now
but I might get junk because 60 on me
was never alone I I was always with a
what a good girl of of the homies of my
best friend it was pretty good I
probably would have got cracked by like
a little Dodger bat or something or
stabbed or something about the homie
Soviet Dodgers yeah those were so scary
as a kid man I've been with little
beaters die die so you got your ass beat
with one yeah I did definitely did I got
cracked about five times
yeah
and the fact that it fits in like me
personally my stomach was a little too
big so it would have like it would have
been a little more uncomfortable for me
you know but but but but [ __ ] you know
the the skinnier homies will hold the
cracker because you know they have a
flat stomach so it feels good they can
decide it to the Bell but Mia probably
give me some little you know a little
rash if I have it there too long rash
against fat is nice it's never too good
you know what I mean but but it
definitely came in handy you know I have
a little hamburger backpack yeah the
streets were dangerous man the streets
but you're out there tagging right
graffiti I love it okay so if you're out
there attack my sister
your family's everywhere no [ __ ] I know
that my sister yeah my sister's a boy
basically bro yeah she's out there
running the [ __ ] streets tagging and
then she started doing chalk because she
said she wouldn't get in trouble doing
art pieces on people's heads of just
sick ass chalk work yeah and everybody
loved it and then she stopped but uh
I would go out with her
and make sure she doesn't get her ass
beat because I'm from her setup up north
it's ghetto as [ __ ] too that's just like
that's just like the armpit of like dog
those like little desert towns is crazy
you've been to Fresno then I've been no
you know Fresno uh I've I've heard like
like so I've been to Oakland and like
San Francisco and people always tell me
like if you look down on the shitty part
that's Fresno and that's when people go
like people go like Stockton Merced and
like it's right my friend will be like
that's it Trevor lives in GTA
when I went to East L.A I was so
comfortable for the first time I went oh
my God Merced oh my mommy lives in East
L.A right that's Whittier yeah Boulevard
I'm like dude this is my hometown I'm
fine just Justice it's just a little
more life yeah more activity more
activity to make more money here for
real and more cars
you guys have horses
people do not walk around the horses in
my [ __ ] on the outskirts right by the
college because this is supposed to
people hella horse they're always going
down the road horses [ __ ] everybody I
went to high school with uh that's one
of their options to go to college
the University of Merced oh because
we're we suck and we make it look real
good online no but also like everybody
that went there has trauma now something
happened to him they know they um [ __ ]
they developed
um like can you develop like anti-social
like 100 and maybe like some depression
a hundred percent because you're so you
especially I grew up in downtown DeLay
So everybody in my area grew within the
people Union West Lake
um
[ __ ] Echo Park area maybe Chinatown a
little closer to like Mid City South
Central and I mean um like West L.A and
with the way where's the city bro where
the [ __ ]
like this is never quiet yeah so I
couldn't imagine going to a dorm and
being roomies with a white crackhead
dude three-story buildings our tallest
building in town
four um
wow there's nothing in my town but drugs
you have kids
so depression and [ __ ] yeah real quick
especially when you're like how do I pay
rent
what how am I gonna pay rent not not
necessarily depression but most most of
them come back within after the year
because they can't take it yeah yeah and
I've talked to some colleges in the
country it's not even in our town it's
two and a half miles outside of the city
you're in the country by fields and cows
bro it's depressing because I mean I'm
from there yeah it's [ __ ] depressing
no I know why you're out here oh yeah
yeah I had to go it was too much it was
a must it was a must no I mean Mercedes
great your hometown's always going to be
your hometown yeah yeah facts there's no
opportunity oh yeah but I'll beat the
dog [ __ ] out of six here with me damn he
doesn't smoke weed he remembered the
question we always [ __ ] go 40 minutes
ago oh that's right yeah I know but yeah
graffiti yeah man I mean it's kind of
like when you grow up in the city like
mine like
kind of embedded to your food like
everybody all three of my
brother-in-laws are graffiti artists so
my sisters basically dated another me
you know I mean just in different shapes
of forms
support for today's episode comes from
True classic the absolute best fitting
teas a man can buy what's up guys if you
shaped anything like me you know Finding
shirts that actually fit you and fit you
well is it's frustrating it's the
hardest thing to do true classic tees
taper at the bottom and they're a little
tighter on the chest just to accentuate
if you're a bigger dude or your husky
guy work with what you got highlight
your attributes with a true classic
shirts they're just made to fit us guys
a little bit better before you even get
a chance to notice how amazing it fits
you're gonna notice how soft this true
classic tee is they have this dope pack
Builder on their website where you can
custom bundle all their essential
products and save even more than the
discount that we're offering you today
they got polos workout shirts boxer
briefs it's the one stop shop for all
the essentials that you possibly need
big dudes tall dudes small dudes all
dudes listen up your girl wants you
looking right get a shirt that fits true
classic gonna have you feeling right
looking right fit and ready getting
ready free shipping included on all
purchases over a hundred dollars hundred
percent risk-free guarantee with a
30-day return policy get 25 off of
everything and anything guys go to
trueclassic.com discount code dope just
type in dope when you're checking out
it's 25 off of your entire order Stay
classy with true classic your dad
Bodwell thank you
tis the season for clean balls manscapes
helping you clear a path to a succulent
holiday season it's the holidays guys
grab some crop mops for your pops or
grab the body buffer for some stocking
stuffers just whoever may need it guys
it's the holidays manscape's a One-Stop
shop for all your holiday needs we got
the Platinum package 4.0 cracking right
now plus all the little stocking
stuffers you could possibly imagine or
need for the hygienic man in your life
and you guys already know manscape is
much more than just trimmers they have
everything you can need for Hygiene
purposes shampoo body wash deodorant
deodorant for your balls gels exfoliants
all the stuff to make you not stink guys
this holiday season here at the podcast
we're only wrapping our privates with
the finest of fabrics that is the
manscape boxers of course and The
Ultimate Gift the lawnmower 4.0 guys
waterproof wireless charges got the
light on it skin safe technology so you
don't Nick Santa sack cheers 2.0
everything you need for Nail Care we got
the scissors we got the Clippers we got
the tweezers the file shears 2.0 new for
manscape so this holiday go beyond the
growing with manscape's full product
line save 20 off plus free shipping by
going to manscape.com Yola so remember
guys 20 off of anything and everything
you buy on the site plus free shipping
when you go to manscape.com forward
slash YOLO that's our discount code 20
off plus free shipping have a dope ass
day
what's the etiquette amongst graffiti
artists like
um I think I think one is like like
obviously with anything that has to do I
guess you say you would say like the
street like obviously there's always
going to be pieces of shits to
everything like why don't you go over my
[ __ ] okay but example right um
so there's a tag right so I don't know
um can people see okay I'm gonna use as
an example okay so where it says the
podcast that's a tag yeah so that's a
tag right and then let's just say the
kiss can people would they be able to
see the push yeah okay do you have
something like maybe bubble like a
bubble okay let's just say the let's
just say the joint it's like it's like
the bubble throw it's like the the
circle throw okay okay that is allowed
to go over that
by any means okay that that throwing is
allowed to go over where it says the
podcast because that's only a tag throws
over tags and then those are straight
letters straight letters over everything
and then so some art and then Integrity
in there and then pieces like you know
you know you ever you ever passed by
like middle Melrose or somewhere
downtown where you see [ __ ] that you
can't even understand yeah but it's like
a name yeah of course that goes over
everything so everything you hit up on
the Billboards so yeah but even like
even like let's say like let's just say
I were to come in here right and you
have this dope ass piece let's say this
like in the Bando and you guys did the
dope ass you saw a podcast piece and
let's say there's like podcast beef then
the rule would be like okay if they did
that I I either gotta go better or go
bigger or do something that you know you
don't break the rules and [ __ ] like that
and there's like spots like um they're
called Landis so like in in my city
that's the there's a guy named plug I'm
gonna say his name plug97 I've met him
briefly or I think Muhammad introduced
me briefly like on just some like
kicking it and we ran into each other
you know graffiti [ __ ] you walk in the
middle of downtown he's somebody tagging
you ask him like what you write and [ __ ]
like that and he has a spot where I grew
up in the back there's a pole that runs
through the through the alley from 1995
to this day is there right now damn
there's a spot that my homie Zumba from
DB has that's from 08. there's there's
nothing I have a spot where my ex
actually it says do know
um hard Ashley I think 20 2016 2017 by
the block where I grew up and and it's
still there till right now so you know
and and that's in the concrete you know
when when they do the fresh paint and
they just you know you get a little
pencil you and then it dries up and you
know the city's [ __ ] yeah part of the
city forever so yeah they're like
etiquette you know what I mean you don't
go over Legend there's a lot of Legends
a lot of legendary tags that you've seen
like man I ran into attacks from like
the like 89 I'm like what the [ __ ] like
89 you know what I mean and that's
something you gotta respect even though
you're like
man they just say y'all like you have
the [ __ ]
Thomas yeah [ __ ]
from 2022 you know with duno and some
[ __ ] little stupid [ __ ] kid comes in
here 10 years later and just ruins it
you're gonna what the [ __ ] I get it you
know what I mean so there's definitely
the more etiquette hey go get me some
water
so there's definitely etiquette to this
[ __ ] you know what I mean no pencils
spray paint mop markers oh yeah
everything everything
um I think like evil okay I guess you
would say with like markers and like
pencils and [ __ ] like that like if
you're a [ __ ] do you know what black
books are yeah of course okay so like
damn I haven't seen one in Forever sorry
about that man oh yeah I have like
multiply my office you gotta y'all gotta
come by when y'all come to my pod yeah
yeah yeah so I have so like let's say
like let's say YouTube right but I give
you my black book and then you do a dope
ass piece on it but you're my homie your
beef has nothing to do with you guys and
I give you the black book and you go
over here [ __ ] it's like what dig the
[ __ ] up my black book by starting to
diss each other and [ __ ] like that like
you're [ __ ] don't do that you know
and [ __ ] like that you know so that's
definitely one of the things where it's
like I guess you could say etiquette
with like markers and black books like
don't be going you know I'm in question
like the one difference I'm hearing you
say
is in Merced it's more of Hayward gang
and here's the tigers that we have in
our gang is what they write it's not
more art where I'm from it's more like
yo let's go [ __ ] shoot somebody look
what you're tagged on my [ __ ] like I
feel like people aren't like there was
I'm not gonna say all the cruise in
Merced but I know what they are all they
did was [ __ ] box and shoot each other
okay it's never like yo artwork like yo
you [ __ ] suck you've been doing this
[ __ ] for 10 years you can't read your
[ __ ] you're a toy oh man okay so I
haven't heard that a long time okay so
like I just think it depends the way you
like your crew care you know there's a
lot of like very R formed Crews you know
I happen to be from La so just you know
shit's always gonna happen people are
not gonna like you things happen like
where people get shot I've been shot
before
um over dagging I mean nothing too
specific but you know it's just la like
it's like like anybody a skater could
get shot in L.A yeah a skater could get
shot in Merced you know what I mean it's
just for sure it's just it's just things
that happen you know people dislike each
other sometimes there's misunderstanding
so that's just really much what it is
um but yeah there's definitely crews out
here that are [ __ ] like both really
good graffiti already artist and also
very good at shooting Cuts you know what
I mean so it's just it's just that's
just that's just what the same [ __ ]
that's just what the streets are gonna
come with bigger version of you you know
what I mean that's just but
you know obviously the the number one
goal is to get up and see [ __ ] people
see your artwork and and dope [ __ ] like
that you know what I mean that's always
dope like you know what I mean see what
your homies and hip like books like
that's fun as [ __ ] damn dude you're
really into it yeah oh yeah oh no no I'm
I'm but you're from New York yeah oh bro
you guys [ __ ] in Mexico Buffalo okay
same [ __ ] you're not too far bro New
York bro that's [ __ ] any every tagger
when I went in New York for the first
time in January I I was like
damn because because every city has the
different [ __ ] different graffiti
style but New York but New York you
mentioned it but New York invented it so
like
they think a hip-hop and graffiti
well Graffiti's part of hip-hop that's
part of the four elements yeah she's
like damn you guys you created
everything fun what are we doing over
here we're just smoking weed on the
beach and [ __ ] yeah yeah um have you
seen the the
um the episode they have I mean the
whole little document industries that
have about graffiti in New York yeah
actually it's an old one old one that's
the first night me and my fiance ever
hung out and they're like white the
little kids are like they're white black
latino one guy has like an arm but
they're older too but they're older yeah
and then it's like two hours long yeah
and then and then there's like one guy
named cap
that just caps everybody like he just
goes throwing circles around everybody's
[ __ ] I don't remember that okay
everything I did the whole entire Canal
took him like [ __ ] two weeks that
white dude if it's the same documentary
he did the took my two and a half weeks
okay no maybe maybe same same people
were into different documentaries but
the one I'm talking about that's where
the name that's where capping comes from
like oh that's what kept me that's what
I'm thinking it's just my theory right
now that I'm a little high you know I
mean it's just my theory at the but yeah
that's like it's an amazing [ __ ]
story I was like damn graffiti was
[ __ ] amazing New York yeah it's they
were hitting the trains like it was that
[ __ ] has to be the same way it has to
be riding on trains while tagging in the
back of it and then there's one guy with
one arm
remember okay yeah man I'm gonna try to
say y'all to leave but that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] because some of his home video
fools running from Cops jumping on
buildings and [ __ ] yes
my little more they they were doing that
[ __ ] but it was a little less but yeah
graffiti is amazing though do you get
into any extreme [ __ ] where you gotta
climb [ __ ] oh yeah man I'm from uh I'm
I'm from a very well-known good graffiti
crew where where um the art is very much
you know uh uh a priority you know I
mean we make sure like well not me no
more you know I'm I'm too busy
podcasting you know what I mean but good
I have some homies that are still very
much in love with the graffiti game so
if you just had a blank canvas what's
your normal thing are you gonna do a
character are you gonna do it oh no no
no oh no I'm I'm I'm I'm what's
considered only could do your name like
I only know how to do the three letters
and do not you know like I just come
over the name dude oh my name doesn't
mean [ __ ]
you know I was like in the sixth seventh
grade trying to figure out life
everybody had a nickname I need one you
know there's a couple it was dude no
[ __ ] there was a couple things that
that went back and forth there was like
I I remember like a dose that shows
trash like DLC and then it was like fat
p-h-a-t-s and there was like multiple
things like I don't know [ __ ] there's
just a bunch of stupid [ __ ] going back
and forth and then I I and then I landed
with um my sister Cookie actually was
like oh don't know
we just put letters together and I was
like hey dude no yeah they don't mean
[ __ ] it literally like nah just you just
made it up just made it up it literally
doesn't mean a [ __ ] single thing
which is like the best thing ever yeah
yeah you should make up some crazy ass
story and tell it and then just be like
no no no I've done so many podcasts
people reach out people be like oh my
God you said the year wrong I'm like
okay I said the story but anyway I don't
[ __ ] follow you and know exactly what
you said every moment that you said it
how many shows you do you said
um I have three podcasts total
um yeah I will I have at the end of the
day on no jumper and then that's that's
you and there's a couple other there's
like three other people it's me and two
other people it's me a DNT rail
Wednesdays at 6 p.m PST time you feel me
every Wednesday every Wednesday Arnold
jumper and then I have the brown bag
that's what you can do to do after this
right that's the one I'm up to do after
this usually we do Mondays but I was at
the hospital that's why I couldn't do
what you guys Monday and I have to do it
today yeah yeah so and that comes out
every Thursday around 4 P.M and Thursday
that's that's you and there's a girl on
that one hey it's me Letty and and
[ __ ] roscrest Vic yeah I'm trying to
keep up with all because I know I see
all the thumbs up I'm like okay that's
that show that's that theme of that show
that's a theme yeah yeah so um there are
different um
um at the end of the day is more like
being at the block with the homies you
know just Clowning laughing we'll talk
about certain things that come up we'll
talk about Kanye and his crazy ass and
we'll talk about whatever blue face and
[ __ ] like that
um we have that and then that's kind of
more clowning we talk [ __ ] we go back
and forth and then I have
um brown bag which we actually have a
live show on November 23rd at the novel
oh I saw you guys you see the no jumper
one there yeah you guys are doing your
own and then I'm doing brown bag with
Lefty and Vic so going back to back this
year you know what I mean that's [ __ ]
it's gonna be a dope time make sure you
guys are there we're gonna have fun it's
gonna be a lot of alcohol we have a
super special guest wouldn't you say
December 23rd no December [ __ ] yeah I
said November I think that's probably
something amazing December 23rd December
20th right before Christmas nothing
about the novo who's the first time you
ever went there who's the first person
because you're from L.A yeah yeah I've
been out there okay you want to hear the
story Stupid in Love 60 or 50 on me I'm
in love with life you know in love with
my girl
um the first time I went to the novel I
actually took my ex-girlfriend which is
the love of my life to go see Kalani
there oh okay so I'm gonna go see Kalani
which was you know
it's a little different for me yeah I
don't know anything just I know one song
you know what I mean that she used to
play that she used to play me and
dedicate me so I took her there and it
was just more like I ran into another
guy that looked exactly like me you know
like cargos white socks and like a black
tea and he was yeah and he was like
and I'm like yeah I don't know he like
me either food
so the girl so the first time I went to
the noble it was like uh the first time
I actually went backstage and was able
to perform and did what I do where I was
like part of the the show was with um
Foods gone wild actually
yeah I hosted it you know he knew my
background he knew I'm from the area
downtown L.A yeah so I was able to host
that I did that and then um
[ __ ] yeah but yeah I see Kalani there
I've seen MC Magic there nice do you
know what MC Magic is it's the D it's
the enemy writer he's the old I'm trying
to say he's an old ass fool but it's
like mid 90s this is old right old food
yeah he's all there yeah like like still
Legend still shutting off I'm talking
like uh
ah with kid Frost's age maybe like early
90s right no um later like 90s I would
say from 97 and up
he's from like the little Rob era oh
okay that's like 99. maybe three yeah
yeah that's when I was [ __ ]
experimenting with drugs first time
getting in the dress how old are you
fool 33. wow you look very young bro I
know people tell you that all the time I
get carded
yeah okay yeah yeah that's why I was
saying damn how old are you 22 but [ __ ]
I'm supposed to talk about your back I'm
like my back started around there and
just fix it now because my [ __ ] still
hurts and it's not getting better man so
yeah fix your back now
um all right so you got the live at the
Nova that's what I wanted to ask like
yeah you know you're at the show hey
what's up fool I don't know I'm just
here and then now you're like I'm on
stage and now fools are doing that and
looking at me it's just a weird
transition and I was born oh yeah you
know it's like uh this is new to you oh
yeah I'm new to like it's it's it's
hosting yeah you're like hosting [ __ ]
but um having people asking you
questions and knowing about every single
thing you talk about on camera and they
see you on YouTube and religiously watch
with their wife husband kid best friend
cousin Grandma whatever Mom Dad
um that's always the best feeling dog
where they have like they know your
inside jokes it's crazy you know people
just comment something go that was from
my four years ago holy [ __ ] yeah they
know the inside of jokes they know what
I like and don't like they [ __ ] don't
ask funny questions
um you know and then I like is to be
specific like on the brown bag we have
like we have a thing called instead of
[ __ ] America we have something called
umino rival
and that's like you would let's say I
would choose Adam vladen academics and
you would tell me Karan I saw that nino
rival so who would you want as your
rival who would you wanna sell that and
who would you want as your Nino and if
you guys don't know what Nino me Nino
means um for Godfather what do you mean
about the me what are you talking about
okay party so [ __ ] man yes who would you
want at the party yeah I've never heard
nobody say a party that I what is
happening
I've never heard anybody say that well
you we're also have a step dad that was
a white supremacist families are
Mexicans bro I've never heard that Mike
you've never heard like hey you're not
coming to the carne asada never ever
heard anybody say it like that in my
life
not even though G and his whole fam
nothing
that's crazy you've heard it before I've
only had the fans in the comments say
Marty's coming to the carne asada I have
never okay okay so you know how black
people go like oh yeah he's coming to
the cookout oh I get what you mean by it
okay never heard that term really okay
so we have the really ever like you're
coming yeah
yeah like like my black homies when they
know it's Valentines I'll be like yeah
can I come to the car on your side of
them and I feel like yeah [ __ ]
yeah when you talk like I do yeah but he
did the accident coming to the carne
asada damn it that's exactly how I talk
yeah okay yeah so we have like this game
and we'll do like I don't know like
Adam's my dog so I was let's say I'll
choose Adam as my nino means Godfather
you know like when you get baptized so I
don't want to be my nino and then um
rival I mean
unless you know what I mean so we have
things like that and then fast will come
up and ask us like oh kind of hunting
arrival and we have like a segment now
called um [ __ ] [ __ ] so we'll find
like funny you know you know what I'm
flaming right cars so like kind of what
they call like low riders like oh that's
my Ram flight like back in the day I
guess you would say like Chicano maybe
cholo like era so we just kind of put a
little funny twister would be like right
around so whoa we'll find cars that like
look like a [ __ ] boat but are driving
down the five freeway or we'll find a
car that says stop Patrol or like
[ __ ] you know and so we'll rate [ __ ]
like that and and people will send it so
you know it's a lot of dope segments
again fans involved too and the fans get
involved we get [ __ ] drunk with them
you know we're Mexican so we have a
Mexican
podcast event you know so we just
[ __ ] get [ __ ] faced we get [ __ ] faced
we get blacked out you know what I mean
we get blacked out shut the [ __ ] up over
there we're [ __ ] podcasting idiot
so we'll do [ __ ] like that you know are
you on your phone with your [ __ ]
nah go outside
by the way shout out Oscar man
yeah so we'll do [ __ ] like that you know
what I mean so well yeah man it's dope
bro and live soon our our adult feeling
you get to meet people meeting greets
are going crazy and you make great money
you know what I mean you're gonna show
your marriage you got to see the people
that come out for you yeah and I know
it's your actual fans facts sick dude
all right all right well first off no I
never heard that term in my damn life
but we do have a segment it's always
called who are you in the 90s but you
were not existed yet you were not born
yet so we changed it up but it's called
who were you in the 2000s okay all right
Marty did this one so basically I'm
gonna ask you or Marty's gonna ask you
two things you just go ahead and pick
and choose yeah you pick you you pick
and choose that's it okay so but it's
Gotta Be You in that mindset like
earlier would you be the shadier 16 year
old self you gotta think of my man 69
jumped me so think of you in the 2000s
not now okay not like [ __ ] you know
about now you know what I mean like okay
what year were you born two thousand
Doug oh [ __ ] a lot of this [ __ ] came out
in like two
yeah so then I could see like even that
like there's like an ongoing joke on a
jumper where like oh do you know because
I always be like Oh I'm 22 I wouldn't
people be like hey DMV wanted me to know
about [ __ ] from like 95 like
[ __ ] I wasn't born and I'm not
like this hip-hop knowledge head dude
they want me to know who will [ __ ]
Jay-Z was dating in 96 like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] idiot you know
all right this is even a little bit more
relevant because we got the part two
coming out right oh okay and it kind of
says a lot about your taste in movies
Dark Knight or Avatar
foreign
love that movie by the way I'm so
excited to see it thank you this [ __ ]
this trailer oh my God bro if I want to
go see I want to go see it um so you
know how to be right before the movie
came out there played it again on
theaters yeah yeah I [ __ ] I want to
go see it again in theaters I've never
seen it in theaters I only watched it
like from home yeah oh it was the first
3D movie I ever saw like IMAX 3D is
[ __ ] amazing dude my grandpa watched
it once or twice three times a week and
I live with my grandpa I was like 19 I'm
like all right grab you wanna watch out
with dirt bike yeah I do great book is
not gonna tell nah Grandpa no he's all
stoked I watched the movie so many
[ __ ] times guys what's your favorite
line I don't I hate it all and keep it a
bug see a little batty on the blue one
when he fall in love with the aliens
daily
she's like a shark
and luckily if you were an avatar that's
what you're going for actually
dead riding pterodactyls and [ __ ] gosh
it was hard as [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] well
that [ __ ] was and you go to Disney World
that's the game you go on a pterodactyl
and you fly but then I get an avatars
all right but part two
we're ready we'll see I'm scared you're
scared it might be not good yeah because
they hyped it up and it's been so many
[ __ ] years it took 30 years to make
or whatever like it's the [ __ ] it's been
a Whole Decade no more when did Avatar
come out she died 12 years ago came out
in like 2007 2008. yeah it's been um oh
more than a decade so what about 13
years 2008 15 almost 15 years damn next
month will be 15 years
I'm excited this [ __ ] was crazy okay but
yeah so I would go with Avatar versus
Dark Knight go now when you were coming
into your awareness and [ __ ] were
iPhones just standard already because my
the next question was sidekicker
Blackberry but that might have just oh
yeah no no no see but I have older
sisters okay so I can answer this the
sidekick what the [ __ ] a [ __ ] ask you
for your number [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
do a kickflip with a phone
that [ __ ] was gonna solve yes
I don't like blackberries
I posted it on Instagram people said
they work for the military or some [ __ ]
yeah okay Circuit City headquarters yeah
so yes I would definitely go with um
with sidekick okay now we're I don't I
don't know these are great movies you
gotta I feel like you've seen them go
okay all right we're gonna see where
we're at here at Movies super better 40
year old version 40 year old version oh
good [ __ ] because made me so horny when
I was I was young when that came out I
was super young but like you know when
she's trying to [ __ ]
Superman is a little cringe to me yeah I
I I I I understand the comic for like
for like super Stone heads yeah yeah
like bro you work out blog posts like
that's every week
he worked that [ __ ] but he worked like a
Best Buy before he was even caught back
come back here I'm gonna air it all out
no but yeah for your version like
[ __ ] love that fool does he not look
like another traveler yeah kinda he
looks like Aaron Rodgers to me now
holy [ __ ] Michael Scott kind of does
look like Aaron Rodgers holy [ __ ] right
that's all I see
discount double check We're not gonna
win next year every time someone's in
one of these commercials their next
season's dog [ __ ] oh yeah man Chris pop
all bad everything's bad everything's
bad yeah Chris Brown need to let State
Farm go he down homes but Holmes threw
it all away the next season all right
well that's a good point I'm not wrong I
know I've seen man Josh Allen came out
that [ __ ] Gillette commercial next
thing you know we're losing so I see it
too you gotta keep it to yourself
Anchorman or Talladega Nights oh
oh Anchorman good [ __ ] I saw Anchorman
the day it came out in San Diego I love
mine I love how he acts it's a good
movie and then honestly I'm not really
good with names but I know these actors
like Will Ferrell and his like
um my favorite movie for me is the um
with the Tropical Thunder no he's not in
that movie
Tropic Thunder that is worth oh no
that's not welfare oh my God
Robert Downey Jr Jack Black another
thing about the basketball yeah the
basketball World Globetrotters no Tropic
Thunder you said that's a different
movie
I'm talking about Will Ferrell yeah yeah
dog how much oh I know what you're
talking about where it's like an old 70s
yeah and he's like he's got the afro
yeah okay oh I just saw it the other day
out of my phone I don't know yeah I was
like I was like I'm not wrong you're
wrong
um uh anchorman's a great movie and I
love him all Step Brothers I was gonna
put uh Talladega Nights and Step
Brothers
basically the same [ __ ] movie
my favorite line on that movie is like
oh Semi-Pro
100 [ __ ]
bro you've seen good [ __ ] movies that
Brothers was a [ __ ] I watched all the
time I'm not even gonna call it my dad
even if there's a fire oh my God kick
that [ __ ] that was the best yeah
that was the best line ever oh my God yo
you watch the outtakes when you go home
watch Step Brothers outtakes just have
fun it's like eight minutes it's them
[ __ ] up and saying two horrible [ __ ]
then like not cut that [ __ ] you got that
one but imagine how hard is it working
with welfare hard yeah
how can I not laugh I'm gonna look down
[ __ ] your mom and then yeah he's like
you're [ __ ] your mouth
I would ruin this every show I just feel
you 100 percent
all right go go for it go for it all
right last one you might be a little
biased here so give us a little insight
into your music which preferences which
we want to talk more about a big beef in
the 2000s which was very relevant to the
both of us game and 50 Cent in the 2000s
whose side were you on oh if if I'm born
in the 2000s we were in hurricanes I'm
I'm I'm I'm from L.A I'm a West Coast
baby so I would probably go with the
game but I definitely like some of the
first things I ever dedicated to
Mitchell was like if I was your best
friend all the time you know what I mean
or 21 questions if a [ __ ] knows you
know 21 questions you know you're a
little different you know I mean I'm a
man like like like if I wasn't
dedicating [ __ ] like little yachty
songs you know I was dedicated [ __ ]
like did you imagine
like I wasn't dedicating you know I mean
like I'm from Atlanta you know what a
great [ __ ] answer yeah it's a great
answer but but but but like I also uh 50
Cent I I know I'm not ah nah I'll still
go to the game bro like James pain the
song here with Keyshia Cole was one of
my favorite songs I've ever heard you
know I I used to love they don't do that
a lot of music now future kind of did it
with Tim's when he did I went away for
you but it's been a while where they
have like an R B singer singing with the
artist oh I love it when like ever since
oh what that changed my life forever
when I was drinking 40 somewhere in
random stairs
I want to hear it call 45 and Tuesday
what oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] are you drinking
Real Steel Mickey's 211. oh I did 211
sometimes when I was when I was stupidly
broke I was down bad okay
I'm pretty sure you guys don't smoke
[ __ ] drink 40s anymore but if any of
the fans do get a Colt 45 I know they
don't have the grass ones no more
actually I think they might have Glasgow
45 Plastics yeah uh it might not say the
same okay got a code 45
I think they ended at like 2016-17 get a
glass code 45 or 40 ounce get a
Blackberry 211 in the cans
listen to what I'm about to say you
Chuck have the Colt 45
and you drink some of the Blackberry and
you mix it
that [ __ ] is the best drink ever mixed
in bum era
that sounds like imagining taste
I'ma throw up no matter what if I drink
that I'm like I'm a chew I'm a puke
tonight because I will keep drinking it
that sounds not bad
but Colt 45 and 211 might be my worst
beers of all time
my dad used to 211 all the time when he
was coming down on [ __ ] cranking [ __ ]
so I used to smell it so even smell it
like
this huh
what what the [ __ ] like we're not
related by everybody out here I swear to
God but yes they're always crushed a
little tilted but not falling down just
crushed enough to be cocktail like our
dads they're like mid and dying over
those but they're like hanging up
that's not funny enough
I got a 211 six pack for three dollars
one time in high school was a six pack
of tall cans damn your old dog I can't
no like this one place would do buy one
get one free they knew bums would come
in just all day all day all day because
it's kind of warmers and and then and
then I'm pretty sure 211 is cheap like
manufactured okay so they were probably
making double the money and no matter
what even if they're giving us a deal
but I'm right a cracked one went I can't
even do it
[ __ ] like it's so bad to me I don't know
why it's that one's gross yeah yeah plus
my liquor is very bad for you that
should make me sleepy yeah uh Mickey
says chug Mickey's do you ever try those
like energy drink not before faux Locos
you remember something called Sparks no
it was orange mixed with
uh liquor and
uh energy drink it was like a mimosa on
steroids yeah carbonated Mimosa there
you go great way to put it Sparks wow
don't they just hug those they just
email you guys like Hey we're trying to
come back
yeah that's my own favorite [ __ ] ever um
[ __ ] my I used to drink ciscos
that's exactly
you ever see brand of cigarettes you're
like damn [ __ ] you are tweaking because
I never heard that brand all the way
disturbing cools cool those are
expensive yeah but they're if you smoke
those your cats just come oh yeah those
are bad for you to smoke those on high
school too not good for you not good I
got over the Menthol after I got over
like the [ __ ] flavored Blunts and I
was done well yeah you know I smoke a
lot but
um that was it for the the questions
right wrap it up cool one more thing I
want to I want to ask because
it says on your Twitter it says tweets
taking my what's your Twitter uh doing
those around the same thing dude knows
where all one yes isn't it like do you
know it's do no but if you look up doing
over there okay so your Tweet says
taking my mom to the strip club today
for a vlog and she has no clue
how did that go down oh it went amazing
yeah it keeps getting ages so we keep
trying to have you know like blur out
cracks and nipples we put it on YouTube
yeah I have to right bro yeah yeah it's
restricted for sure but but of the title
my mom I mean if it was us yeah for sure
yeah we have [ __ ] with a lot so I'm
like you have to blur that out no just
do a black screen and a sound that's how
much we get [ __ ] yeah yeah so we've
been so so we've been kind of going back
and forth a lot of editing has been
going on we I'm waiting on it people
aren't anticipating but yeah at the
moment of the strip club she actually
enjoyed it mom's very feminist she's a
very big Pro woman my mom could my mom
in this world a man it's just as much
equal as a woman a woman just got the
man you like you're not better yeah just
because you're a little stronger like I
don't give a [ __ ] you know what I mean
something about my budget dude to the
face oh yeah I'm hearing like I learned
how to wash at a very young age even
though
still don't do it you know I mean if I'm
very much able to wash and wash dishes
and make myself some eggs and yeah a cup
of noodles and some cereal you know and
I mean it doesn't take a [ __ ] you
know but I know I have a homie that
can't wash I'm like [ __ ] you
don't put white with color [ __ ] oh I
like that like [ __ ] don't mix don't put
like [ __ ] like isn't it odd when
you meet people that never have done
[ __ ] like I was doing that at six yeah I
was doing that [ __ ] I was doing that
since stupid young and and that also
happened maybe be super um
like I'm just super [ __ ] like when it
comes to women I'm just very like you
know I'm very like sensitive towards
them just for the fact that I got three
other shoes in a mom but yeah
he's making all these 50 Cent mixtapes
and dedications yeah I'm a [ __ ]
cornball huh
but you have to go to the strip club but
she was just like very supportive of
them didn't want to put her face in
their ass maybe she's like she cares
about her skin a lot but you know I mean
yeah you know I like my mom slap that
she's like a little small pigeon like
trying to kill somebody and she was like
a little penguin like
she was like typing in with their thing
with her just her fingers like but she
was down yeah but she was down
they motorboated her like ah she was
like how old is your mom then my mom is
47 right now oh wait you're 10 years
younger okay okay okay this makes sense
all right yes yeah I'd have to go take
out a senior citizen ask him to let me
borrow her for them
mom three old decisions I'm like I'm
expecting my friends moms you know
because my mom's not like a regular
mamas well it's fully tatted takes
mushrooms and [ __ ] oh [ __ ] she's
different oh yeah like Superman that
that that see that makes a little more
sense when you explained your mom I was
just thinking she didn't teach Spanish
she's not she'll speak Spanish oh she
doesn't speak Spanish either my mom's
the my I was raped by my mom shows me
Spanish okay my dad I'm the only one in
my family doesn't speak Spanish out of
every single [ __ ] person in my family
on my dad's side everyone also [ __ ] them
for not teaching me couldn't have taught
me but you want to talk [ __ ] at
Christmas
you could have taught me I was there
sorry continue yeah your mom is dead
yeah
yeah and my mom's also a different um 47
year old mom she had us young went
through a lot you know I had we she had
trouble kids a very troubled first
daughter that would run away a lot um
she put my mom through a lot to have a
great relationship now my audience just
for my mom she um and she had like a man
that she loved that was on drugs so
imagine having to take take care of
three three little kids and
being worried about your 13 14 year old
daughter looking for in the streets for
about two months plus or in and out of
juvenile hall or just you never knew
what was going on plus dealing with a
crackhead husband that you love her and
trying to help it's a lot so my mom kind
of took a pause on her life just to
raise and have money to feed and yeah
because in their back but the minute I
15 14 15 you know I was kind of
bothering you in the hospital I'm not
listening to the judge I'm not listening
to you but obviously she was still my
mom there for me very dirty we have a
great relationship but like now we're
all older I have a great I have a great
um I have a great career going on that
is still growing my sisters live on
their own I'm the only one that's still
a mom oh no [ __ ] yeah my mom's at Rock
Soul every other week she's a [ __ ]
punk she loves to her my mom's husband
you know how like most mom's husband
would be like Juan Gabriel my mom's
husband is [ __ ] Jim Morrison dog like
that's that's what she has him like on
her wall like like she's a 13 year old
girl like and then she has like this
little thing that we got it like a
record player and she just she has a
bunch of old discs because she's like
every morning that's what she does oh
yeah my mom does not know English but
we'll tell you about
10 plus songs from the doors The Ramones
you know [ __ ] exploit you know what I
mean it's my mom's a fan of System of a
Down she's you know where we're a big
rocker family yeah no [ __ ] Scott music
you know what I mean
you know what I mean red store bums we
listen to all that when we were kids
that was like their getaway like you
can't find a babysitter we're bringing
you to the tocada that's what it's
called and that's like a rock so you
know what I mean we'll get a mosfits my
dad would either have me or the girls in
it in his shoulder and just [ __ ] so
now when we kind of bond we do family
things we'll go to Rock shows together
and I'm the one that has to get the
tickets because I know the guy you know
what I mean yeah now it's like
like do you know anybody from here most
of the time it's like yes I'll be like
all right let me hit you yeah no it
should constantly remind me like she
she'll remind me every day I leave oh
yeah you got those mushrooms let me know
when you got those mushrooms that's how
my mom is now so it's so weird being
like but it's cool because it used to go
from like you know I mean the wheel I'm
able to do that now so that's double up
and then I was like oh it's from my mom
it's not even for me oh yeah but we got
extra four tickets on trips yeah and she
be up there calling me like my name's
not on the list I'm like telling this
okay okay okay bye bye bye bye clicks I
don't even get a [ __ ] no no thank you no
thank you
to say no with an accent right now
thank you
oh [ __ ] all right well yeah damn that
sounds like my mom that's [ __ ] weird
yeah I'm on a lot of mushrooms now and
my mom she's same thing with my mom she
had to write my mom she had my sister at
15 me at 17.
my dad was on [ __ ] drugs the whole
time crank is crazy you know so it's
kind of the same [ __ ] I grew up in the
it was only ODB or the doors or Pink
Floyd when I wake up wow great music
peace Floyd yes one of my favorite bands
oh yeah man I love the doors
yeah but see I get it from Mom and Dad
like they were big fans of like the
Smiths too yeah my mom's using the punk
that's her that's her main I love this
man what's missing that punk but he's
like Morrissey yeah the Smiths that's
how my mom is yeah I think all Mexican
ladies love Morrissey oh yeah I don't
know what it is it's the European in
this dog something like I always just
want to be like really depressed the
[ __ ] dance like this
you're not really dancing but you're
you're feeling you're just moving yeah
you know yeah you know I mean the
Mexican is trying to do some some like
Merengue but then the more seen you just
gets depressed he sits down smokes a
secret yeah so we have a great time yo
where are we at where are we all right
cool all right uh before we get out of
here
dude
um you have upcoming event which is
December 23rd and that's the Brown Bag
podcast yes yes we have to know we have
to know we'll get your tickets if y'all
want to have a new podcast too also you
know benefit this podcast you guys could
get a real Mexican and then uh you know
I mean uh uh non-speaking Mexican you
know you you get bad you get good at
both worlds you know we got a real
Mexican and then Thomas yeah yeah hey
man I'm Brown [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah I
guarantee if we get pulled over I'm not
whitewashed all right I am still proud
man officer
officer
and then your hair just wins it off my
hair no it's just my way usually it's
usually cut and done right but I don't
give a [ __ ] lately yeah I also both like
married fiance vibes yeah married yeah
we've chilled their fiance yep yeah yeah
you guys don't even care about your hair
no more right she's gonna give a [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] I got with April 15 years ago
she started cutting my hair
every no matter what yeah you got a
different hat on that's Marty's thing
because I mean I usually have my hair
like done and cut and combed and all
[ __ ] news anchor I'm tired of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] over it man it was a good
20 minutes before each episode you're
[ __ ] jealous now I'm more like No
Country for all men hey we might die no
all right real quick before we get out
here your YouTube is Juno's world as
well Twitter Instagram Tick Tock Spotify
just put on them so you never got to
leave nothing oh I have I have but yeah
but you know for me we got it back you
got it back dog that's different oh man
do they fly you guys shut it off for
smoking weed
we'll try to like wait a little because
it's just sometimes yeah you need to
check that I feel like I'm mad at it
I've been trying to like usually that's
starting my podcast like hey what the
[ __ ] is going on it's your boy
I'll start like the the Vlog like what
the [ __ ] going on today with the name my
camera I'll be like I'd be like okay
what's going on you guys what's up with
your boy doing nothing I feel like a
[ __ ]
his first thing was what the [ __ ] is
going on that's how he started every
episode we kept getting the age
restricted we're like dude this is
[ __ ] up the views at this point we
gotta like what's going on man like 10
minutes [ __ ] you dial it back yeah it's
a little bit just started yeah you two
kind of gotta figure that a little bit I
don't know I like the fact that we can't
curse
if you're gonna have YouTube kids just
have YouTube kids and just have YouTube
be for adults that's all I feel like
yeah because dog YouTube like yeah
YouTube is like it but I'd be like
they'd be every chick to me for girls
shaking their ass but be showing kids
getting bombed in Iran or something I'm
like yeah what the [ __ ] is going on over
here the stuff it suggests me is like we
say I can't even say the titles of these
videos in an episode because it'll it's
interesting episode even though that
video isn't murdered I'll tell you after
but the video that we got as a
recommended video over our episode
is unreal I can't even say on the
episode because we will get [ __ ] this
one age restricted just saying picture
of the most horrific thing in jail
racism I don't even know how to explain
it anyway Doodle's world all right yeah
we're worth wait there every you said
every Wednesday at six you drop um so
every Wednesday at six we have um uh at
the end of the day it's okay it's live
on a jumper oh it's a lot yes it's kind
of like the Tuesday show oh they're all
live yeah we're on live we're all live
and then and then they save after right
they say so we have um oh [ __ ] no you
guys are live switching cameras yeah
yeah so they have like the thing yeah
yeah so um so we have that and then we
have um I have brown bag it drops every
Thursday from 12 to 4 P.M we usually
just kind of usually 4 P.M and then we
have um and then I have cheese man with
duno which is like a interview segment
kind of podcasting still it's still
growing still trying to figure it out on
my YouTube but I have that where we um
where we do see it like where I
interview artists and different people
and [ __ ] like that and we have a good
time yeah kick it Vibe she's never doing
now so yeah just put our new music video
I just um yeah I just dropped Foods gone
ravery you know I'm fool who's got raped
oh that's my question for him to ask too
you know I'm trying to get into the edmc
EDM scene house music and [ __ ] like that
so that's a Vibe yeah we kidding it man
we're doing all types of [ __ ] yeah I was
with the LA Raves that was one of my
questions I forgot to even ask because I
know La Raves are still a thing oh yeah
part like events and parties for sure oh
[ __ ] sick
90 people in the house I'm like I gotta
go to school dad in the morning you
[ __ ] Tweakers figure it out figure it
out
anyway all right now but thank you for
being here man this is amazing I had a
really good time here I think I'm a
little faded too thank you
a little bit I can see it over time you
smile more like Grinch I mean at least
get up to some [ __ ] nah but thank you
dude um so everybody out there check
them out Juno's world uh no jumper
podcast no jumper uh channel is where
you're yeah Wednesdays when drops on
Wednesdays and then and then brown bag
we have our own channel it's called the
Brownback podcast on YouTube as well
Instagram all that we do have a show at
the novel December 23rd so go get your
chicken then I have cheese man we're
doing on the regular doing those World
YouTube channel also Pro club.u no
proclubusa.com or just go to my ear bio
yeah or just go to Pro Club
um on on [ __ ] Instagram and don't
have the thing right there you know I
mean you'll find it man you got this
more Marty let's go thank you man this
is inspiring I love how you're just you
got so much different stuff going on
across the board yeah man I gotta keep
working getting after it as an artist
that's what all the I talk about and
hopefully by our property about this
comes out next week right yeah okay but
hopefully by the end of the beginning of
next year he has um I I sh my little
part at white man can jump should be
coming out you feel me what [ __ ] a white
man can't jump what do you mean the
movie Yes wait they remade it they
remade it with Jack Harlow stop it swear
to God he quotes this movie and talks
about this movie every other episode you
got a part in the white man can't jump
yes sir whoa congratulations holy [ __ ]
you're forever cemented in cinema now
yeah holy [ __ ] and and in that part I'm
actually with Andrew Schultz and Jack
Harlow
damn I swear to God they got the two
tallest white guys for White Men Can't
Jump
he's not that tall though being tall
doesn't mean you can jump I know but do
you hear what I'm saying it's like yeah
yeah you got two white guys that might
dunk that could possibly I mean I mean I
mean they could have got Adam nah he
don't fit the road Adams tall as [ __ ] I
I know because I took the patient went
damn and then we took the picture and
went [ __ ] bro look at your little nephew
at this point yeah but yeah man there's
a lot of things so y'all go follow me
and make sure y'all catch up part good
[ __ ] get another we're making that [ __ ]
no dude would have told me right over
text immediately yeah this is one of his
favorite movies bro so yeah they're
making that man it's a good [ __ ]
congratulations bring back Rosie
um I'm not I'm I I [ __ ] I'm not too
sure about the other parties I don't
know Bob the little part I was in which
I can't talk about but I was I was in
the little part yeah yeah and yeah did
my [ __ ] you know I spoke Spanish in it
oh [ __ ] Latino we were being represented
nice and wear my ketchup yeah over here
too dude
all right man thank you so much for
being here all right guys it's been the
dose usual podcast appreciate you for
being here have a dope ass day bye all
right
these were Donuts
foreign
[Music]